the immortal Iron Fist has fallen so as
people probably heard last week I think
it was last week I don't know my like my
days bleed together at this point
talking about the stuff is continuous I
do not a complaint it's just kind of
what happens but iron fist
is not getting a third season it has
been officially canceled so this is the
first of the Netflix series to sort of
get this kind of definitive clothes
arguably you could say the same thing
kind of happened to defenders except
that was always kind of positioned as
more of a miniseries rather than an
ongoing thing so that didn't so much get
cancelled it didn't have to because it
wasn't planned as an ongoing season of a
show but they have said that they're not
planning to do more like it so maybe you
can count that as two so let's go over
the situation this leaves things in for
Marvel Netflix in terms of what shows
are left and what may or may not be done
with storylines and characters from Iron
Fist warning upfront I am going to be
talking about as much as I know about
all of these shows so if you are not
caught up on some of these like I'm
probably gonna drop spoilers so that
means first two seasons of daredevil
first two seasons of Jessica Jones first
two seasons of Luke Cage first two
seasons of iron fist the defenders and
as much as I know about what happened in
Punisher because that I've said before I
I wasn't engaged enough to finish it I
know the people liked it great I'm sorry
I didn't but in any case so iron fist
gone that it's it's very clear they
hadn't necessarily counted on that being
the case because they did leave some
very clear strands that could be picked
up at a later date at the same time
though it did sort of bring certainly
that chapter of things to a close now
I've gone on right last time I talked
about these shows in general I sort of
basically sort of rang the death knell
that I read
we thought all of these were gonna be
wrapping up soon and that honestly I was
probably wrong about that he's looking
like that's not necessarily the case
because my prediction was that with
Disney coming up with its own streaming
service that they were gonna wind all
these these down but you know apparently
not yet at least not on mass they're
gonna play them out on a one-on-one
basis or at least that's what it looks
like now based on what's happening so
with Iron Fist out I figure there's
three characters that we are liable to
see again in other shows and those are
actually the three who have been in
other shows so that would be Danny Rand
himself the iron fist
Colleen wing and misty Knight if I were
to peg where they're liable to turn up I
would say Luke Cage season 3 would be
the most likely now let's be clear Luke
Cage season 3 has not been announced as
yet it has not been confirmed so if that
doesn't happen maybe we don't see them
again and all because I honestly think
that that's the world of the story that
slot that those guys could slot in the
most smoothly into without like
disrupting everything but I do feel
comfortable and saying we are probably
gonna get a Luke Cage season 3 because
even though they haven't announced you
know a date for the for the new season
or you know a start a filming or
anything like that not only was it left
in a very clear position to set things
up for further stories given the time
frame that we got with iron fist in
terms of when the season closed and when
they announced the cancellation it
wasn't that far apart all things
considered so given how much time it's
been since Luke Cage season 2 I think if
they were gonna cancel it we would have
heard by now so even though as of
recording we don't have a confirmation
of Luke a season 3 I'm still expecting
it and that's where I would expect these
guys to turn up again which makes sense
on a lot of levels especially given that
iron fist himself has been teamed with
Luke Cage repeatedly in the comics so
what I don't expect to have happen is
something that I have vocalized before
that I would like to have but I would
like a daughters of the Dragon series I
would like Colleen and Missy to have
their own show because the chemistry
between the two of them are apps is
absolutely great and I
felt that their stuff was a lot of the
best stuff in iron fist season to I'm
not expecting that to happen because
while I will again admit that I was
wrong that the Marvel Netflix shows were
on borrowed time I would be shocked if
any new shows started up I suppose it is
possible for them to spin-off from their
own stuff but I really wouldn't wouldn't
expect them to get any new material to
play with because Marvel is gonna put
that on Disney's own streaming service
when that comes out so next year the
year after I can't keep track of this
stuff anymore but I I'm not expecting
any new shows from Marvel Netflix I
expect them to ride out the ones they
have for hour however long they feel
it's appropriate for each of them so
let's look at each of them because if I
had my way from a narrative perspective
most of these would be wrapping up with
their next upcoming seasons and I'll
talk about this and I'll explain why
eret of lis that's why I feel that would
be the best call do I think that's
what's gonna happen no but I'll come
back to that
so daredevil season 3 obviously the one
we know the most about is the one we
have a trailer for so if this is truly
going to be the coming to a head of
kingpin and daredevil then that kind of
like one of two things has to happen
either
it's gonna bring a definitive end to the
kingpin in which case you know you've
burned through the best villain you've
got I mean I would say the best asset
the show had overall and if it doesn't
and it just leaves it in a hanging
situation like oh no we're gonna stretch
this out for more seasons I think
they're really gonna risk diminishing
returns and I think they're gonna I
think they've got this upcoming season
to have the impact of kingpin versus
daredevil really properly landed if they
just stretch it out for four or five six
seasons keeping him around I don't think
I don't think fans are really gonna care
for it and if they take out kingpin and
keep the show going it is gonna feel a
lot like well you've peaked already what
is there left to do I
and it is unfortunately troubling that
it has again no if no seasons have
officially been confirmed is happening
but Marvel folks have said that there
are at least plans and proposals and
outlines for what to do as far as six
seasons in for daredevil which concerns
me because there's a lot of shows out
there that are good shows but should
have ended one to three seasons before
they did like they clearly hit their
peak some of them even have what were
clearly intended to function as final
episodes and then kept going past that
and it very rarely ends up being a
rewarding experience when that happens
you're just kind of waiting for it to
finish so like that's why I feel like
that should that narrative Lee feels
like it should be closing out with
season 3 I kind of feel the same about
Jessica Jones which I believe is
currently in the process of shooting and
that one is a little less clear-cut but
if they are going to build season three
around the conflict between Trish and
Jessica which would be the logical
extension of where they left things off
at the end of season 2 then again that
feels like something that you could
justify as having you know becoming to a
head of the last at least one if not two
seasons worth of television but then
it's like well where is there left to go
after that again obviously there's room
for them to set things up but given what
they've made Jessica Jones into which is
not what the comic was the comic was
very much a here's the latest case
Jessica Jones workout and the show is
not that the show is much more a new
building arcs out of her personal
journey
I think that's harder to stretch out
over time and have it work I already
personally feel that season two was a
serious step down from season 1 nowhere
near his focus nowhere near as polished
nowhere near as clear in what it was it
was doing Luke Cage which I already
mentioned it ends in a very godfather
fashion at Luke Cage season 2 did which
to me means we should be setting up Luke
Cage season 3 to basically be Godfather
Part 2 and before you think oh but there
are three Godfather's no there are not
in any case I would think that you know
going down the path of
cage sort of taking filling the void
left by the local crime bosses in Harlem
that he is now filling however he
chooses to do that whether he is just
taking this stuff over whether he's
trying to dismantle it from the inside
who knows we'll see when we get there
but I feel like that that again feels
like a crescendo it feels like an ending
on a high point that one at least from
what has been built up in terms of the
season that came before I feel like that
one might have the most potential
mileage to get a fourth season out of
because if the third season is about him
trying to fill this vacuum however he
does or whether he goes all in on being
the bad guy or whether he's trying to
you know ease things back again who
knows if he falls out of that position
at the end of that you could have a
crawling crawling back from the fall as
a season four but again it depends on
where we get left in season to the
Punisher this one I have to just go by
what I am beware because as I said I
didn't finish the show they the thing is
the reason I am inclined to say season
two feels what I know of it what has
been said it feels like it should be a
last season is they set up basically
Frank's only notable recurring villain
which is jigsaw Frank doesn't get
recurring villains because he kills them
so you can't really have too many
recurring villains with the Punisher
jigsaw is pretty much the only one and
now that they've set him up they've now
got to do that story and then once he's
out of the way well what is there left
to do I suppose depending on what they
do with Frank's own development as a
character they could figure out more
angles to tackle with him personally I'm
not sure how much more there is to get
out of this particular version of Frank
though if you are gonna lead up to him
taking on what is in the Netflix version
you know somebody who is very much from
the world he left behind you know in
terms of being military based and
everything else so it would be a
confrontation of not only someone who is
a version of his one iconic foe from the
comics but it could be framed if done
correctly as him confronting his own
past in his own history
on which I think honestly is a lot of
potential
will I watch it I have no idea but you
know that again that feels like a climax
that feels like a like a ending on a
high point will any of these end with
their next upcoming seasons probably not
I mean again it'll probably be ratings
dependent and that's pretty much
impossible for us to judge because
Netflix does not release their streaming
and their their viewer data it's not
like Nielsen ratings where you know you
can just look it up so it's really hard
to say I would say that daredevil season
3 is probably gonna pull in good numbers
and if it is anything close to a return
to form that the first season 1 it's
going to pull in good numbers and have
good reviews so I can unless they
completely drop the wall and blow it
with the introduction of bull's eye and
we're bringing back the kingpin which
you know given that the kingpin has been
even in season 2 in like the 1 or 2
episodes he appeared it has been the
strongest element this also I'm not
expecting them to drop the ball with him
so unless they do I would expect we're
probably gonna get at least a daredevil
season 4 cuz I am predicting a very
strong and positive response to
daredevil season 3 Jessica Jones I think
is a lot more up in the air I think that
has a very good chance at season 3 being
the end because again going by my
reaction and the reactions of you know
those that I've you know looked at and
seen general a general response that I
can come across even people who like
season 2 seem to feel that it's a step
down from season 1 and I have a feeling
that season 3 is gonna deliver some
diminished returns already in terms of
the viewers because basically you know
first season was I I know not everyone
liked it but for me was amazing and then
season 2 not as good and then season 3
he's probably gonna have lower numbers
because people will have done season
doom been like that I saw how good the
show was gonna be I don't expect it to
get any better and so I think that one
has a decent shot at killing it off
after season 3 and Luke Cage I err I
already talked about but like I said the
question becomes how long do these
things
run and I again copping to the fact that
I was completely wrong when I said the
entire thing was gonna wind down when I
made that prediction it's it's now
clearly on a case-by-case basis show by
show and I think the ones that have the
best shot at moving forward further on
down the line are gonna be Luke Cage and
and daredevil daredevil had I think the
you know the overall the strongest sort
of backing from fans and again we don't
know of you or numbers but I if I were
to guess that probably had the best
numbers Jessica Jones you know that
first season felt like you know a real
it had a point it had a purpose and the
second season didn't pull in the same
enthusiasm so it gives the impression
that this show trying to come up with
new storylines is not gonna hit the same
really resonant themes that it managed
to get in its first season Luke Cage has
a good chance of moving forward because
it kind of became a little bit of a mini
cultural phenomenon with between you
know him being a black superhero being
in Harlem dealing with on the ground
street level you know problems of a
culture that is not always depicted as
heroic in in crime media especially so I
think there's enough interest in wanting
that to you know to really sort of
justify the the enthusiasm for it again
my feelings on the Luke Cage seasons
have been mixed some people like him
more than I do but I think there's
enough goodwill based off just sort of
what it is and what it represents and
what it could be if it if it truly you
know nails it that that will keep that
that will hold people's interest longer
people will give that one a longer leash
I think whereas Jessica Jones sort of I
came away from that first season going
I'm skeptical about even a second season
because this was so tight and so focused
so good the second season kind of proved
to me like you guys came into this with
one clear story about what you were
doing and now you're just kind of
throwing stuff together and I don't know
for certain if that was everyone else's
feeling
but if that feeling is shared by
audiences
in general then I don't think goodwill
is gonna keep Jessica Jones going past a
third season but yeah even with Ironfist
canceled I severely doubt we've seen the
last of Danny Rand definitely and
Colleen misty probably because you know
that I we don't know exactly what the
contracts are like but I have to imagine
there were clauses in their contracts
that will enable these shows to keep
these characters on the hook for at
least some guest spots in some of these
shows like I said Luke Cage makes the
most sense to plug them into what I
think we will not be seeing as far as
leftover stuff from iron fist I doubt
we're ever gonna see the Meacham's again
I doubt were ever going to get Kunlun
stuff again we're never gonna see this
friggin dragon and Davos and you know
he's connected to Conlan and any
lingering stuff about the hand I don't
think we'll ever see again either
because that was basically stuff that
even though some of it had appeared in
another show especially the hand and he
kind of initially showed up in daredevil
it kind of was the big thrust of iron
fist and if they're looking at iron fist
going people didn't really go for it I
can't imagine that they would transport
those story elements over the characters
like I said could be plugged into other
people's stories lifting those story
elements that ends up taking over a
narrative if you try and stick that in
someone else or so so I expect all that
stuff to be gone but Danny misty Colleen
may be probably gonna turn up again if I
were to bet next season of Luke Cage but
that's sort of my ramble and my thoughts
on the current state of Marvel Netflix
in the wake of the cancellation of iron
fist what are your thoughts on whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
whole bunch of stuff you that you can do
because there's buttons and there's
links including one to a patreon if you
feel like supporting me in that way that
would be awesome but you know what if
you don't want to don't sweat it because
at the end of the day you are the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]